Grape-Nuts is a wheat and barley cereal developed
by C.W. Post in 1897, and it has actually
made some interesting contributions to American
food history.
A box of Grape-Nuts actually contains “whole
grain wheat flour, malted barley flour, isolated
soy protein, salt, whole grain barley flour,
malt extract, and dried yeast.”
It also boasts a number of essential vitamins
and minerals.
From what I could find, the recipe has remained
largely unchanged since its introduction over
100 years ago, save for making the switch
to whole grains.
So just how did Grape-Nuts get their misleading
name?
According to Post Foods, there are two versions
of the story about how Grape-Nuts got their
name.
The most plausible theory is that, as Post
used maltose in the original recipe which
was called “grape sugar”, that’s where
they got the “Grape” part.
The cereal also has a bit of a nutty flavour,
which is where “nuts” came from.
Alternatively, some believe that the cereal
looks a bit like grape seeds.
Those seeds are also sometimes termed “grape-nuts”,
even though grape seeds are not nuts, nor
are such things as almonds, peanuts, Brazil
nuts, etc.
Personally, I’m strongly leaning towards
the former theory as the correct origin of
the name.
So I mentioned earlier Grape-Nuts have been
at the centre of several historical events.
For instance, the cereal was the first wide-spread
product to feature coupons.
In this case, they were “penny-off” coupons
which became a big hit in the 1890s.
The coupons were for other Post cereals—they
were trying to get people to buy more of the
product, and it worked.
More importantly, Sir Admiral Byrd might never
have gone to Antarctica if it hadn’t been
for Grape-Nuts.
The expedition was sponsored by the cereal
in 1933, making it possible to send the first
two-way radio transmission.
In addition, Grape-Nuts promoted the expedition
by putting maps of the route on the back of
their cereal boxes.
During World War II, Grape-Nuts were featured
in soldiers’ rations, fueling the troops
during battle.
Because the cereal was light, compact, had
a long shelf life, and was nutritious and
healthy, it was a perfect item to include
in rations.
Similarly, Grape-Nuts saw Edmund Hillary and
Sherpa Tenzing Norgay to the top of Mount
Everest.
The two would, of course, become the first
people to reach the summit of the mountain,
and they took Grape-Nuts along with them to
keep them fueled on the long, strenuous climb.
In addition to expeditions and army rations,
Grape-Nuts also sponsored The Danny Thomas
Show, a popular series during the 1950s.
If The Danny Thomas Show doesn’t ring any
bells, you might recognize a character that
appeared in the show during an episode that
was promoting Grape-Nuts: Sherriff Andy Taylor.
During the show, main character Danny visited
Mayberry where he met up with Andy.
Viewers loved the Sherriff so much that a
spin-off series called The Andy Griffith Show
was born, which of course became an instant
American classic.
Post ran a number of successful ad campaigns,
including several commercials that ran during
The Andy Griffith Show featuring Sherriff
Andy Taylor and Deputy Barney Fife.
However, Post’s Grape-Nuts started becoming
less popular as time went on, probably due
to Post being sold from one company to another
and not having a consolidated, consistent
marketing plan.
That’s when they decided to make the switch
to whole grain, a staple in the cereal’s
recipe today.
They thought whole grain would be more appealing
and keep up with the healthy image they were
trying to project.
Ironically, in addition to being made of neither
grapes nor nuts, Grape-Nuts aren’t all that
healthy, either, though compared to most breakfast
cereals perhaps one can consider them relatively
healthy.
Back in the day Post boasted that Grape-Nuts
would “fill you up, not out.”
However, it has since been found that the
cereal has a Glycemic index of 71, higher
than such sugary cereals as Fruit Loops and
Frosted Flakes.
Further, table sugar only has a glycemic index
of 60.
So Grape-Nuts is perhaps good for a quick
energy spike before a morning workout, but
the downside is that aside from scenarios
like that, the cereal inducing a pretty large
blood sugar spike could lead to insulin resistance
(and later potentially Type 2 Diabetes).
It is also fairly high in calories, leading
to a small recommended serving size which
most people promptly ignore, filling their
bowl up with an absolutely massive amount
of calories.
This further potentially contributes to obesity.
Therefore, it’s likely going
to “fill you out” along with “filling
you up”.
So, essentially, the
cereal
is a lie…